bonjour bassin et un merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu un pas tignes de trêve pour le
moment entre arménien et azéri malgré
les appels à la désescalade de la
communauté internationale et notamment
des présidents français et russe
et quelle autre solution pourrait être
envisagée à court terme pour calmer les
tensions
je crois que évidemment il faut essayer
de neutraliser diplomatiquement airs
douanes qui a dessiné ou planifié cette
guerre avec les azéri durant cet été
d'où par exemple l'importation si je
puis dire de combattants mercenaires
djihadistes que ce soit de syrie ou de
libye ce qui est attestée
si le ministre des affaires étrangères
russe le dit c'est que c'est vrai mais à
part ça on avait des sources bien bien
informés qu'ils le disent qu'ils
affirment
sarr le retrouvent dans les sites arabes
qui parle d'une délégation turque qui
était venu à et free ont recruté des
turkmènes pour aller se battre on a un
ballon contre les arméniens ou alors des
mercenaires arabes ou d'autres
nationalités qui était en libye comme il
ya une sorte d'accord en libye ils ont
été dépêchés en azerbaïdjan et ça
remonte au 21 juillet on avait des
informations là-dessus
donc je pense que tant qu'il n'y a pas
eu d'intervention de la part des russes
et des français
la guerre va continuer et surtout que ce
sont les azerbaïdjanais qui ont attaqué
contrairement à ce que leurs médias
affirment que c'est les arméniens du
karabakh qui ont attaqué c'est pas vrai
du tout hein
parce que toute la ligne de démarcation
du franc s'est allumé à 5 heures du
matin à l'aurore par des tirs des
missiles des hélicos des drones turc
voyez s'était bien préparé ben ça vous
prend vous parlez de vous parler
d'intervention russe ou française
comment pourrait justement intervenir
ces deux pays parce que vous voyez il ya
ce qu'on appelle l'accord de bill sq où
ce sont les etats-unis la russie et la
france qui sont chargés ou responsables
d'amener la paix entre le karabagh et
l'azerbaïdjan
donc si vous voulez d'office
ces trois pays sont nommés pour essayer
d'arrêter les combats maintenant on sait
que trempe soutien un peu un peu
beaucoup à perdre one pour le garder au
sein de l'otan donc c c'est lui qui lui
a permis d'abord d'occuper le nom de
l'aciérie maintenant ils ferment les
yeux sur son rôle en azerbaïdjan il faut
bien donc
la russie et la france qui ne partagent
pas les mêmes visions politiques
d'autres ans intervient pour arrêter
cela d'ailleurs notre président français
macron l'a dit clairement qu'il
s'agissait pas enfin en aucun cas de de
permettre aux azerbaïdjanais de
reprendre le karabagh saynètes
maintenant la russie l'a fait savoir
aussi mais la russie a beaucoup plus de
poids parce que là c'est sa chasse
gardée cette région le caucase et ça peu
influent ça peut influer sur la rue si
vous voyez les terroristes il sent déjà
en les as en azerbaïdjan
ils peuvent passer de l'autre côté et
qu'on mette des as constat je ne sais
pas moscou à petersburg je me sais sous
la selle sur vous pouvez vous parler
d'intervention
française ou russes on sait que les deux
pays appellent à cesser le feu mais
concrètement qu'est ce que peuvent faire
les deux les deux pays des sanctions une
intervention militaire comment on peut
imaginer cette intervention des deux
pays concrètement je crois que pour la
france elle peut intervenir par sanction
quant à la russie elle peut intervenir
vraiment militairement
parce qu'il ya des bases russes haut
karabakh et en arménie et comme je les
dis c'est sa chasse gardée et la russie
est plus proche de en fin de la bataille
disant que la france
ceci dit la france au type faire
pression en aide ont franchement lecture
de la manifester plus d'une fois et il
faut mettre terme à ces gesticulations
dangereuse vers dwayne ce n'est plus
possible
à il n'arrête pas la lune et des francs
un peu partout en il faut sanctionner la
turquie c'est parce qu'elle alla
l'intervention turque dans cette guerre
est plus que clair et j'aimerais finir
en dit long aussi que personnellement je
suis parlementaire de l'armée dit roxy
long terme c'est à dire c'est par mini
occupe la turquie jeu mais ceci dit je
puis vous assurer que les renseignements
que georges est donné sans tout relève
d'une objectivité
enfin sans parti pris merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup bassin maintenant d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes ce politologue et
islamologue merci beaucoup